- Gary and I have known each
other, we have this reference
that we've known
each other in passing.
Even though Gary
lives in New York,
the only place that
we've actually seen each other
or gotten together is
Austin for South by Southwest,
San Diego, we've
shared the same stage,
Mexico City.
- That's right.
- And we'll be in Australia
on the same stage--
- Am I going to Australia
or is that the hologram?
- You beter go to Australia.
- I think it's the hologram.
- Your name's on the flyer.
- I got this
new hologram racket.
Cool.
- Alright, so I
asked him to come down.
Well, my people asked his crew.
Without blinking
an eye, he came here
and, trust me, we're
all industry individuals.
It wasn't about what's in it
for me, what I'm gonna get.
Very, very solid guy.
So, I respect the
fact that he's here,
and he didn't
want anything from me.
So, thank you for
being here, thank you
for being with my family.
- You're welcome.
(audience applause)
Thanks for having me.
- I wanna get
into a couple things,
and then we're
gonna open up the Q&amp;A,
and what I wanna
know, first of all,
this is my
Rise and Grind Series.
And, I don't
wanna talk about low,
not low, but things that
startups need to know,
because the whole
concept of Blueprint and Co.
is you already have
the blueprint of business.
You already know
the fundamentals.
You need now to move forward.
And, my last book,
which was "Rise and Grind"
was about-- no, my last book,
which was "The Power of Broke"
was use the assets
that are in front of you,
and I know that Gary
believes in the same thing.
But, today, I want to
talk about the methods
that successful people have
that they do every single day.
When you were
growing up, did you have
a rise and grind mentality?
- When I was
growing up, there was a lot
of interesting
things going on with me,
which is, I was an immigrant,
and education was the way out
for immigrants.
Probably, still today,
but, extremely,
entrepreneurship is "new cool".
It's an American thing, but
if you were an entrepreneur
in the '80s and '90s,
if you said that word,
that means you were
a loser with an idea.
(audience laughter)
And, so, I was in
a very weird place.
My whole world,
outside of my parents,
were telling me
that I was a loser.
My teachers were
telling me I was a loser,
my friends' parents were
'cause I was
getting D's and F's.
And the only way you were
scored as a child, at all,
there was no,
you know, I never understood
how in eighth grade
I'm making $3,000 a weekend,
and I'm a loser.
Because I have D's in science.
So, I think, when
people ask me like struggles
or things of that
nature, my narrative,
for most of my life,
probably from eight years old
to sixteen, seventeen, eighteen,
was, I was positioned as
I would not be successful,
because I wasn't
gonna go to Harvard.
- [Daymond] Yeah,
I gotta look back,
and I never saw anybody,
the only entrepreneur
I saw that looked like me on TV
was Fred G. Sanford,
the junk man--
(Daymond drowned
out by Gary's laughter)
- Yeah, it wasn't
even a conversation.
I wish, you know, first of all,
I don't truly wish,
I envy nothing.
But, it would've
been really cool
to be growing up
me during this era.
Right, it would've
been really fun.
First of all, my
parents and I always joke
that I would never have
graduated high school, ever.
If eBay came out a decade early,
I would've sold
my entire family,
let alone everything
in the house.
(audience laughter)
So, yeah, look, I think
everybody deals with stuff.
I love competition, right.
I love competition, so I think
that's really saved me.
Even when
I don't have adversity,
I fabricate it.
As a matter of fact,
I secretly, secretly think
that I've held back
my financial upside,
because I love
the process so much.
I genuinely know that
I could be more wealthy,
and sometimes think
back to the last ten years
of some of the
decisions I'm making.
I prefer the hard way.
- [Daymond] Do you
like the process because--
- [Gary] 'Cause it's my oxygen,
the process is my oxygen.
- Do you often feel
that people cheat you
if you go, and you give, and
you hire them for the process
and you don't know it?
'Cause I always
feel like someone
is gonna hold me
hostage in my business
if I don't know that process.
- Yeah, I don't even
think about other people.
(audience laughter)
I'm being dead serious.
Like, it's unbelievable how much
zero outside influence hits me.
And, so, Instagram's really
interesting to me right now,
because it's an
important platform,
I'm spending a
lot of time on it,
but it's probably the
most motivational version
of myself, right?
I only have a minute for video,
and I can only do
quotes, and pictures,
and so I'm fascinated by
that's where my growth is
right now, yet it's
such a single sliver
of who I actually am.
It's just one piece
But, the reason
I bring that up is,
it's hard to explain,
that's why this is fun.
We can sit here
and really get deep
into this stuff, in detail.
I don't think
about outside forces.
So, when I say things
in a one minute video
of who gives a shit
who the President is.
One way, left,
right, I don't care.
That's one version of
me talking about this.
I'm not worried
about anybody else.
- [Daymond] So, what was it
during your coming up,
your rise and grind,
what did you do methodically
every single day?
Tell me what you
did when you were 15
in your first 90 minutes
when you got up,
and your last 90 minutes,
to what you did today.
Has it changed?
Because you obviously
got educated somewhere,
so you cared about
what somebody was sharing,
'cause you could
absorb it one way or another.
- So, the one
consistent in my life,
I used to have nightmares.
This is actually
something I've never said.
I used to have nightmares,
and it was a very
reoccurring nightmare for me.
It was that my family and
I were going back to Belarus
on a plane, and
the plane would crash.
And, every time,
different people from my family,
usually one to three
people, would survive.
It was very dark, and
probably, in modern parenting,
my parents would be
forced to send me somewhere
to check out what
was wrong with me.
But it was consistent.
I will tell you,
I had that dream 50 times.
50 times between
second and seventh grade,
I dreamt that my
family had a flight crash,
and one or two of
them would survive,
and we'd walk through
snow, and it was very weird.
The reason I
tell you that story,
and the reason,
you asked the question
in an interesting way,
15 and now.
The only consistent in
my life has been perspective
and gratitude.
It's the only
consistent in my life.
Why I'm saying
"perspective and gratitude"?
Every morning I wake up,
and I make pretend
that my mother or
children or wife die.
Every day.
Every day, I did it today.
I quickly flash in my
mind what it would feel like,
'cause I'm very
in tune with myself,
if my son Xander,
who's four years old,
got hit by a car
crossing the street.
I promise you, if you're
in touch with your feelings,
and you can trick
yourself to feel it,
even right now
I felt it a little bit
and it really fucking hurts,
nothing else matters.
I'm completely
driven by gratitude.
I keep things in
very simple perspective.
I went up with
a very lovely lady
in the elevator,
she goes,
"Do you know how many
people you've inspired?"
I go, "Sure do."
I'm thrilled and
very in tune with my ego.
I'm also very thrilled
and in tune with my humility.
I think I'm the best,
and I think that if
I disappear tomorrow,
nobody really gives a shit.
And, so, that yin and
ying is very important to me.
And, so, what I do consistently,
and have for thirty years now,
is I keep things in perspective.
This feels real nice.
Admiration, fans, selfies.
But, I don't know.
I'm just,
I've got it very calc,
I understand what it is.
- [Daymond]
Everybody in this room,
they probably
were like you and I
when we were focused on our
career, and getting there,
you know, Mark Cuban
was funny when he said,
"A girlfriend said it
was me or the business,"
and he said,
"What's your name, again?"
(audience laughter)
- So, you know, we all
got to that point, right?
In our lives.
At what point did you get
to the point where you said,
"OK, now I have
to flip the 80-20,
and now I have to go and
start being with my family
and I have to make track with
that timing and I have to,
because you probably had
a healthy paranoia like me,
like, "Listen, I've
done so much to get here.
"I have to stay,"
and before you know it your
life can go like that, right?
Blam!
And now I know
it's extremely important
to go home with your family,
I have a new 11 month old,
and I know you,
you have a young baby at home.
At what point in
your life did you say,
"Wait a minute, let me
find a healthy balance,"
or did it start
from the beginning?
- I haven't.
(audience laughter)
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna tell you
guys the truth, I haven't,
meaning I run them in parallel.
I'm not crippled by the
current political correctness
of parenting.
You're looking at a
kid who didn't see his dad
until he was 14 years old,
and we have the greatest
relationship of all time
and I love him, and he
slept home every single night,
but I never saw him once.
That doesn't mean
my workaholic nature
will work for me and my kids.
I don't take that for granted.
I think that you
need to know how to breathe.
I know what makes me breathe.
My family makes me breathe.
But I've gotta
do what I wanna do,
like I have to.
I'll just break.
And so, I think
of it as in extremes.
The reason I answered,
"I don't," is I don't think
you find balance in any way
other than your own balance,
and I think that over
communication with your partner
and the variables in
that relationship are the key.
Right now, I have that
conversation with my wife.
In coming years, I'll have those
conversations with my kids.
But for me, I'm very
concerned about people
posturing to work-life
balance, when I know
that work-life balance
is extremely individual.
Everybody in here has
different work-life balance.
You also have different
work-life balance
at different times in your life.
I didn't have as
much work-life balance
as some other
people in the last 5 years,
but it now also
allows me to afford
to have work-life
balance with my children
and my family in a
very different way.
As my daughter
Misha's now seven,
and she can go on
business trips with me.
The only conversation
I had to have was with my wife
saying, "School's bullshit.
Be okay with me taking Misha
"out of school for two days."
She might miss a science test,
but she'll always remember
going with Daddy to
Anaheim, he gave a talk
and then we went to
Disneyland for the day.
(audience laughter)
Right?
So, I think that my
answer to that is I haven't.
I work on it every day.
I communicate it
with my wife often.
- [Daymond] Do you work
on it internally, 'cause--
- Internally.
- [Daymond] 'Cause I wanna know,
what do you do, because...
I have 10 (audience
member coughing) goals set,
it's the first time I
ever read this thinking goals,
when I was 16 years old.
I goal set, and every single
night, five nights of the week.
I read 10 goals at
night before I go to bed,
'cause I want to
dream about those,
and I read the same
10 goals in the morning,
when I wake up.
- [Gary] Does that work?
Because I was, like in high
school, I used try to dream
about hooking up with chicks,
but then it would switch
quickly to some other shit.
(audience laughter)
- [Daymond] Well, my six goals,
are about health, faith--
- Good. (audience laughter)
- and things,
five and six months, and then
I have three other goals,
five years, 10 years, 20 years.
Do you have any
kind of method like that?
- No.
- [Daymond] As you said,
you're working on it?
I'm the most
binary dude you'll meet.
I love the journey.
I wish health and happiness,
like health for my family
is like, like big!
I feel I, you know,
you guys have known me
and I've known myself
through a very lucky period,
which has been my entire
life, which is, you know,
three of my four grandparents
died before I was born,
or one died right after,
so I never knew them.
We have a very small family,
right, I have three
cousins, you know, so,
I just haven't dealt
with a whole lot of death,
like, you know, I think when
I have to deal with death
in my inner circle, I'm curious
how I'm gonna play it out,
but I'm really binary, like
I love the process more than
the riches and the fames.
I have that goal to
buy the New York Jets.
That makes it fun,
that's a big goal.
It'll take me
some time to do that.
When people ask me, "When
are you gonna buy the Jets?"
and I always say,
"25 years from now,"
they're disappointed,
I'm pumped.
(audience laughter)
I've always found that,
that it's amazing to me,
(audience laughter) like, like,
they're like, literally disapp--
I'm like, "It's
three billion dollars,
"I have work to do."
(audience laughter)
But, yeah, man,
Daymond, I'll tell you like,
I want legacy.
I think the reason I'm
liked is 'cause I'll reply
to somebody who says
they're on the way here
to see me talk on
Twitter and reply to her,
like, I, I've, I'm
playing a different game.
I, Tyler's filming
today's DailyVee,
I met with a former employee
and he flat out,
like broke the wall,
and he was like,
"Dude, I just have to ask you,
"like, why did you
take that meeting?
"It's a former employee,
one that you fired.
"One that came to tell you that
"they were sorry
for not getting it.
"She pitched you stuff.
"You didn't get
anything out of it."
Like, I think the
way you put it was,
"You could've used
that time to make money,
or some, or do business."
and I said, he
said, "Why'd you do that?"
and I said, "Because making
money isn't the only thing
"that interests me."
- [Daymond] If you want
crappy meetings,
you got to come on
Shark Tank with me.
(laughing)
What keeps you
up at night, Gary?
And I'm not
talking about the health.
We established that already.
- That's it.
That's it.
Because everything
else I'm in control.
In business, I'm a beast.
Like I will always be
successful in business.
I was from six years old.
And I am now.
Like some people are pretty,
some people are athletic,
some people are
you know, whatever.
I'm a fucking ninja at business.
(audience laughter)
I am, I know how to make money.
- So what are the productive
tools that you emphasize?
And I know that
hard work is by far.
- Well, it's the
most controllable.
- Yeah.
- Like you're not, you know it
feels so controllable to me.
When somebody complains,
so, people get
my message confused.
They're like,
you're always talking
about hustle, where's life?
I'm like no, no, no, no, no, no.
If you're 100% happy like I am,
then I got no advice for you.
You've figured it out.
But you know who talks to me?
You know who cries to me?
I want my business to be bigger.
I want to make more money.
Like that's what
they're talking to me about.
So if, when my rich
friends complain to me about
not spending enough
time with their family,
they're really easy
to give advice to too.
Spend more time
with your family.
(audience laughter)
This shit is binary.
This stuff is so basic.
We complicate it.
- Yeah.
- So to me,
I'm telling you the truth.
Like one thing I've been
thinking about a lot lately,
it's funny that
you brought this up.
Literally last night,
it took me a little bit longer
to fall asleep than normal.
'Cause I was on a high,
I flew to San Francisco,
took a one hour
meeting and then flew back.
I thought that was
funny and interesting,
and I enjoyed the
commuting to San Francisco.
And it took me an extra
30 minutes to fall asleep.
And it made me
realize, oh my God,
I fall directly
to sleep every night.
Every night.
Which I think speaks to peace.
Like I go to, I mean
360 days a year,
I fall dead
asleep within seconds.
You could walk into my
house, rob the shit out of me,
'cause I'm sleeping.
(audience laughter)
- [Daymond] Just thinking
about how much you curse.
(audience laughter)
- I'm keeping it clean.
- [Daymond] Yeah I know,
I know.
You know we all have
these fundamentals in business
that got us someplace
and I think that I drifted
away from it at a certain point.
So many of us do when
we get to a certain level
of being comfortable and happy.
Is there any
fundamentals that you revisited
because you lost
them at certain point
where you thought
they weren't necessary?
- I lost my hustle,
and I don't talk about
this that often either,
but I've thrown it
out for a few minutes.
Around 29, there was a
six to nine month period
where clearly to
me I was complacent.
I just got married.
You know, and so
that was a new variable.
Yeah, I just
remember my 30th birthday.
Literally my 30th birthday
I was driving to the store.
I looked myself in
the rear view mirror,
and I said
"You're full of shit."
"Your mouth is
ahead of your actions."
"You ain't buying the Jets,
you're not, going to buy a jet,
"you can't buy a jet airplane."
"Like get your shit together."
And that's literally when I
decided to start Wine Library TV
and go into the Web 2.0 thing.
And so I revisited my
hustle on my 30th birthday,
and I've never
worked harder since.
And it's been compounded.
I am working
harder right this second
than I ever have
in my entire life.
It's why I started DailyVee.
Just wanted to put
all of you on notice.
Like, you're not
working as hard as I am.
And I wanted to do
that because people think
they're putting in enough work.
They're just not.
I'm just having
hundreds of conversations
where people thought
they were working hard enough
for their ambition.
That's the key.
Like, if your ambition,
your ambition
dictates what you have to do.
And I'm happy when
people have ambitions
that allow them to
work 40 hours a week
and they're thrilled.
I just want as
many people to fall
asleep at night the way I do.
And I think the only
way you really do that,
is you have a real conversation.
'Cause everybody's
bullshitting themselves.
Putting that you're a CEO
in your Instagram profile,
doesn't mean that you're
a successful entrepreneur.
Means you're trying to be one.
- Let's talk about some
CEOs and some innovation.
You know many people in this
room were public speakers,
they advise people.
We go around the world
and we speak to people.
I notice, I don't
know about you,
but half the time they want
me to talk to their staffs,
or anything else.
It's about innovation,
thinking outside the box,
how do you get people
within their corporation
to be motivated?
You find that the same thing?
And if so, how real are they,
real are most of the companies
doing something about that?
Or are they just
sitting there and they talk,
ra-ra-ra, they clap their hands,
and they go back to the
same crap they've been doing.
- That one.
Because the leaders of these
companies are full of shit.
Because they didn't create
the framework for innovation
in their organization.
They just want to
point fingers and say
you need to be
innovating better.
Yet the rules and
the bonuses, and the game
is structured for not
innovation.
And the reason you
got such a heavy head nod
is people know that.
Like they tell you to innovate,
but then when you do
anything outside the box,
they put you right back in it.
- [Daymond] Is there
anything they can do?
Companies that have five people.
Companies that have 5000.
What can they do?
What are the
first steps they can do
to really activate
it without disrupting
their current operations?
- The most practical
answer I've ever given
anybody on this is
take 20% of your money,
your energy,
your organization, your people
and make it go rogue as fuck.
Let them play, let it play,
however you want to define it,
with no rules and
then run your company
with the 80% that's left over
and build a good
enough company that
that 80% can afford for the 20%
to be a negative ROI experience.
- [Daymond] Are there any
companies out there
doing it right?
What companies can you
name that are doing it right?
- I don't know.
The truth is one
of the biggest reasons
when people ask me
who's doing it right?
Or who's doing it
right on social media?
Or which companies
are doing it right?
I don't know.
I don't know because I
didn't look under the hood.
A lot of people
think certain things
are going great and they're not.
Don't forget, Daymond,
this is something I want a lot
of the youngsters in
this room to think about.
If you're under 32 you need
to hear what I'm about to say.
You've lived
through a great economy
every part of your
professional career.
It's been good for the
last eight or nine years.
It just has we've bounced
back since 2009, '10, '11.
We've only been growing.
There's only been growth.
No matter what anybody says.
That's what's happening.
So, I'm very concerned
about the next bubble burst.
- [Daymond] Lets talk about
that.
So I'm not
getting into politics.
That's not what we're here for.
We're here to talk
how to empower ourselves.
But, lets talk about this.
- Yes.
- [Daymond] Whether
it is, is somebody
gonna make this country great.
Whether it's I'm
gonna stay on welfare,
whether I'm
gonna go to a school.
Let's talk about the
number one job for males
in this country
is driving trucks
but when autonomous
vehicles come around,
Uber drivers and males are
gonna be out of business.
Lets talk about the
number one job for females
are secretaries and assistants
but virtual assistants
are coming around and they're
gonna be out of business.
No matter who's
matter America great.
I'm 50 years old
and I'm driving a truck
and I'm gonna be happy
because there's gonna be
an 11% growth in
the next five years
then all of a sudden, bang
UPS, bang American Express,
Postal Service, Uber,
automated, you're all fired.
What am I gonna do then?
Because I'm sitting here
telling you that America's
gonna be great and
I'm gonna be good forever.
- Yeah, I'm mean look
that's going political
like anybody,
anybody that thinks
the President of
the United States
whether it's Barack or
Donald or Bernie or Hillary
is gonna help them,
they're a fucking loser.
(audience laughter)
Straight up.
- [Daymond] Absolutely.
- I promise you, you are.
(audience laughter)
Whether your president is
for minorities and females
or your president is for
the 26 year old white male
that's got no skills.
Here's the punch line
the market is the market.
What is the 54
year old gonna do?
Adjust or lose.
- [Daymond] Right, but
how do we get that message
out and say you know
what you could probably drive
a truck until you're 55.
You can program in tech
and do those 'til you're 90.
Talking to BMW, they said
that they can't get enough
kids to be technicians
because their theory
is the old mechanic
with the big
grease on his shirt.
I was talking to the head of
the heavy machinery operations
meaning crane operators.
They said their jobs
are empty for 15 months.
These kids can go
to school for one year.
Come out making $150,000
but yet they're
going to a school.
50% of them will
retire with a title
of a job that
doesn't exist today.
They're staying in
school for four years.
Half of them
are digital classes.
They're leaving
with $300,000 in debt
and they still don't
know how to operate anything.
How do we get the parents in
this room to save that money?
How do we get the
kids in this room,
well not kids in this room
but who's gonna
watch this online
to understand what they
need to do to move ahead
and not think a
diploma is gonna save me,
the president is gonna save me,
welfare is gonna
save me or anything else.
What happens then?
What needs to happen?
- Carnage.
Carnage needs to happen.
People are complasive.
Here's most
people's strategies in life.
(audience laughter)
- [Daymond] You
holding your breath?
- I really have no
passion for this conversation.
If you are not capable
in 2017 to Google shit
and figure out what's going
on in the world, fuck you.
(audience laughter)
I'm being really serious.
What role does
the government play
or thought
leaders or this and that.
Whatever that cliche statement
of like the teacher comes when
the student is ready, right?
I believe in that thing.
I don't know,
lots of things happen.
Lots of things happen in life.
I woke one morning and realized
you know what this
liquor shipping law
is never gonna get better.
There's dirty politician money
they're gonna
keep paying this off
and I'm not gonna
spend the rest of my life
worrying about
what the right thing
to do is and what's right.
No, they're gonna keep
paying off the politicians
state by state and
because I'm the biggest
I'll always be
picked on so I adjusted.
I started over.
This whole Wine Library thing
and I got so lucky, guess what?
I own zero percent
of Wine Library
'cause it was
under my father's name
so I had no
collateral to even start it.
Started VaynerMedia
by getting somebody
to pay me $80,000 to
do a marketing campaign
and I've built it.
So that's what's gonna happen
and everybody has their version.
Not everybody has
my business talent
to build billion
dollar companies.
But, if you're making
$74,000 or $197,000
or whatever you're making
and your market gets fucked.
I don't see truck
driver Johnny feeling bad
for Rick the bookstore
owner cause Amazon came along.
(audience murmuring)
This has happened forever.
This is not the first
time innovation fucked shit up.
Nobody's crying for the
farmers in middle America.
Nobody's crying for
the people in Cleveland
who owned the docks.
This is what always happens.
So this is whats up now
and so what 55 year old Charles
has to do when he is out
of a job is get another job.
Whatever that job is.
So if Charles is
smart and has skills
he's teaching
himself something now
to be ready for
three years from now.
But, Charles
wants to watch football.
But, Charles wants
to drink at the bar.
- [Daymond] So he
needs to put his 20%
into what's going on in
the future and bank that.
- Mister, that's right.
You're damn right.
I wanna stay on
this for a second
'cause this is
massively important.
- [Daymond] No,
it's very important.
We talk to people everyday
and they just don't get it.
- Then they will lose.
We have to start
getting into meritocracy.
Like somebody
should lose if they're
not seeing where
the puck is going.
If you're driving a truck today.
You know it's coming.
You've heard it.
Somebody told you.
At a bus stop, at a
truck stop, over dinner.
Somebody brought up this theory.
So either you take it seriously
and you start educating
yourself or you don't.
That's the game.
Nobody's gonna fix that.
Nobody can help you with that.
That's life and
that's the historic nature
of human beings forever.
Just cause we're now living
and it's out turn to
go through something,
this has always happened.
- [Daymond] You're right. It's
just happening faster, I think.
- Great, adjust!
- [Daymond] So, let's, let's,
let's go shallow for a minute,
so let's talk about
social media today.
I think that, I recommend
your book always,
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook,"
but, you and I
are having dinner,
and I think that you said to me,
"Well, I on to,"
you were doing Snapchat,
then you want to
Instastory this and that,
and I said, "You know,
most of us grew up with,
"you know, you know,
don't be a jack of all trades,
"be a master of one, and
I wanna kind of do this,"
and you reminded me,
kind of the joker, you know,
when he said in
that Batman movie,
"I'm like a crazy
dog chasing the car,
"I don't know what
I will do when I get to it."
You just move on,
move on, move on.
I said it before,
you have way more influence
on social media than I do.
Obviously, you're
doing something right.
How do you, you pick
which one to move on from
and just keep going and
it compounds on all platforms,
'cause they all
come together somewhere.
Just explain to me your theory,
because it's broken my theory
of be the master of one,
and not a jack of all.
- I think I'm the
master of attention,
I'm just not romantic
on a micro where it is.
So I think I'm speaking
the same language as you.
I think my
master isn't Facebook.
My master craft
isn't to tweet well.
My master craft is to know
where all your attention is,
and to be there and
put out quality content,
that brings you value
contextual to that platform.
So my master ship
is attention trading,
and then we're
looking at social media.
Like, you guys are
gonna have a real brain twist
if you've got me as the
social media guy in 17 years,
'cause I'm gonna be
onto something else,
or not!
I have no idea, but
wherever your eyes and ears are,
I'll be there.
- [Daymond] I'm gonna
open it up in one second,
when to turn on in one second,
don't turn on the
live feed right now.
I just have to ask you
another question man to man,
so, I've gotten on the same
stage as you a couple of times
and you...
You will curse like a sailor
(Gary laughs)
like, really bad!
I will get on after
you, and I will say,
"Yeah, she was pissed!"
and then they'll
pull me aside and say,
"The word pissed, like--"
(audience laughter)
So, and I think
you know, might not be ABC,--
- Yeah, of course.
- And I do
whatever I have to do,
- You're fancy.
- get a little bit of respect.
Why do you, why do you
believe, not that you believe,
why do people buy that from you?
I understand
there's keeping it real,
but I mean, there's
keeping it raw, right?
Why do people
accept that from you,
and have you lost
money because of that?
- You just beat me to it.
Plenty of
people don't accept it.
I wish CAA was here
right now, Zach, you here?
No?
(audience chuckling)
Like, we've lo-,
I've lost tons of money.
I just don't give a fuck.
(audience laughter)
- Okay, but--
- I, here's what happened.
If you think,
here's, here's the truth,
I've never
really clarified this.
I wasn't a public speaker,
I owned a liquor
store in New Jersey,
I was a businessman.
(audience laughter)
I'm 32 years old
before I ever took a stage.
Like, I didn't know,
like, I wasn't a personality.
This was, this was
not in the blueprint.
Okay?
(audience laughter)
What happened was, I got invited
to an internet conference,
I'm like, okay, I'll do it,
and who the heck
knows what happened?
They gave me the mic,
I got up there,
and the best way
I can explain it is,
in my formative
years of growing up,
I listened to an obnoxious
amount of Richard Pryor,
Chris Rock and Eddie Murphy,
and when I watch
the way I give keynotes,
I do think it's got a
comedic timing delivery,
in the style of
those characters,
and so, I guess
that's what happened.
- [Daymond] And that's how you
did it, because of course,
most people would
say, "Listen, I'm dyslexic,
"I got left back, and I never
graduated high school."
Alright, you know,
my, my friends,
they wrote the
movie Belly about him,
so trust me, I've cursed
once or twice in my life.
Some people would say
it's a limited vocabulary.
Some people would
say that, you know what,
it's, it's a, it's an
inability to be articulate,
- [Gary] Yeah.
- and you know, we know
you're a smart guy already.
You come with the
most important thing,
which is common sense.
You don't feel that any time,
you should adjust that?
I already know the answer,
but I just wanna hear it.
(audience laughter)
- No, I think if you're
gifted with not worrying
about anything else,
you just roll.
If you feel that I offended you,
or that I'm crass,
or that I'm not good,
or what have you,
that's your truth
and I apologize.
It's not gonna
change how I roll.
- [Daymond] So, hold on
one second, I just wanna try
one thing while I'm with you.
- Okay.
- [Daymond] Fuck!
(audience laughter)
- How'd it feel?
- It felt good.
- [Gary] Yeah!
(audience laughter)
- I like that, I like that.
Alright, so we're gonna,
we're gonna open up,
we're gonna open up
to some live stream,
and really quick,
we're gonna have
a couple of
questions from Twitter,
and then a couple from
the people in the audience.
So, who will
give me the questions.
- [Announcer]
Yeah, so let's see,
we're gonna start
with the audience first.
- Awesome!
- Start with the
audience first, okay.
- Let's do that!
- [Man] Can we
come back there?
Do you just want
to yell out loud?
- [Natalia] Oh, okay, fine.
- [Daymond] Yeah.
- [Natalia] I have two
questions.
Can I cheat?
- Yep.
- [Natalia] So first one.
I have a crew of people,
like ten of us here,
we would love to
take a selfie with you.
- Done.
- What the questions
everybody is gonna
have to learn off tonight.
Maybe that's possible.
But please, make sure
that everybody in this room
learns off of your questions.
- [Natalia] Amen, yes.
- Amen.
- [Natalia] Absolutely.
The lesson here
is to be bold, yes?
- Yes.
Done.
- [Natalia] Question number two.
Question number two my name
is Natalia from the Bronx.
- Hi Natalia.
- [Natalia] And my
girlfriend, Brittany.
- Hey Britt.
- [Natalia] She's from Miami.
And we have
Muscles and Millions.
We are just starting out.
We are a lifestyle
and clothing brand.
We are about fitness
for entrepreneurs-
- [Daymond] Muscles
and Minions?
- [Natalia] Millions!
- [Daymond] Millions.
I wanted to make
sure everyone heard it.
Muscles and Millions.
- [Natalia] It's the
Bronx coming out of me.
- Go ahead.
- [Natalia] Millions. So my
question to you GaryVee
is we saw, we
noticed you put a video up
regarding #BizDevSunday.
- Yes.
- [Natalia] We sent the email.
Can you expand on that
and how do we get you to
work with us and how
do we get endorsements?
Like what do we need to do?
- So, I'll try to make this a
learning moment for everybody.
- [Natalia] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
So I think, you know,
I'm a big fan
of jab, jab, jab, right hook.
I'm able to duck
right hook, right hook,
right hook, right hook
and so I think the
biggest way for me to do things
is when I feel like
there is value in return.
When you get to,
I mean I couldn't imagine
what you're living through.
I think the biggest
way to get somebody
who's got more
leverage than you do
is to disproportionately bring
them value to even the score
to make something happen.
- [Natalia] Can I?
- Yeah.
- [Natalia] We DM'ed you
and I offered you tons
of shirts and hats and stuff
and you never responded.
(audience laughter)
- Right.
I'll tell you why.
'Cause everybody did that.
(audience laughter)
- [Natalia] So now I'm here!
- [Daymond] Alright, we go
to go on to the next question.
- I think it's
about bringing value.
Your t-shirts
bring me no value.
- [Natalia] Okay.
- So you need to figure
out what brings me value
and then you have
a shot of executing.
- [Daymond] So we
always teach that it's really
what's in it for the
person you are pitching
not matter what
you are pitching.
Whether you are waking up in
the morning and trying to get
to the bathroom
before your husband or wife
or you are trying to get
your child on the school bus.
And you say, "Please,
I'll take you to Chuckie Cheese
"if you just get on
the school bus right now."
It's always what
you are pitching.
We all get pitched
that type of stuff.
But you have to find
a way to bring value.
And honestly, you
most likely will see him
again and again and
again if you are persistent.
But the day that he feels
you're going to be successful
with or without him and
you can bring him value
then it's worth a conversation.
- [Gary] I think tenacity
is way more commoditized
than people think.
- [Daymond] Exactly.
- There's a lot
of people hustling.
It's a value exchange game.
The reason I've popped
and have this fan base,
is there's a lot of
people saying hustle.
There's a lot of
people putting out content.
I'm disproportionately
trying to bring more value
in detail and motivation
and effort and engagement.
And I do answer
a ton of DM's but
I answered DM's the
entire six hour flight yesterday
from Instagram.
I didn't even get close
'cause I'm one dude.
And nobody is replying as me.
'Cause that's not me.
Nobody is replying as me.
You ever get a wink or a hello
or a I can't wait to see you.
That's me.
- [Daymond] I'll give you
one last one before we go.
When I used to
have shirts like that
and I couldn't get
an artist to where them
I would that artists
crew and their name on it
and then I would send it to them
that it was a collabo with us.
And I would tell
them take all the proceeds
and I'll sell it to them.
Take all the proceeds and give
it to your favorite charity.
- [Gary] And when he did it,
the supply and demand of
lifestyle brands was much lower.
It was more expensive to do it.
It was harder.
He figured it out.
The amount of people that
have some fucking saying
on a t-shirt right
now is unlimited.
So you've got a
real fucking challenge.
'Cause the supply
and demand of your game
has gotten much worse.
- [Natalia] And we're ready.
- [Daymond] Alright.
- Good. Do it.
- [Daymond] Next question.
- [Man 2] This is a
questions for both.
- [Daymond] And then
we'll go to Twitter.
- [Man 2] Both Gary and Daymond,
which ever one wants to answer.
But I work with a lot
of young entrepreneurs
through Venture For America
and the one issue is I'm
curious how you guys judge
when you're working
on a new business
or you're investing
in a new founder
how do you know when
to tell them to give up
or how do you know
yourself to give up?
Because you want
to be consistent.
You want to keep
working and figuring it out.
So what's your solution--
- [Daymond] I want
to expand on that
with that question for Gary.
I want to know exactly
that and I also want to know
when you are working with them
what you instill in them as well
when they are on their path.
So when do you
tell them to give up
and what do you say, you
need to do this everyday?
- So I think the key
is to not be consistent.
Because you can't give
consistent feedback
for everybody. Like,
I want to give feedback
based on what
I was feeling there
but I might feel
something different here.
The key is I found
that somebody is either
impatient or too patient.
And so that is
always a key for me.
Like, some people are romantic
and some people are
not romantic at all.
And so I think I'm usually
pushing in the other direction
where they're over indexing
'cause that usually
tends to happen
in the balance
of what they need.
Some people are
just going to hold on.
So I just did a show,
right with Apple,
where we are doing these apps.
So I mentored people.
It was little bit different.
We had to be like "The Voice."
We had to coach them.
This one girl just
didn't want to hear it from me.
I'm like, "You're
not going to win."
Like this is
not going to happen.
I gonna be right or wrong but
I was pushing her to be,
she was so romantic
and in outer space
but she didn't
want to let go, right?
On the flip side,
there was other people
that were kind of rocky.
And I'm like, "No, no,
you've got something."
And pushed towards it.
So the truth is when I look
at young entrepreneurs
I don't give blanket advice
I give individual advice of
the moment of where they are
and what their business is
doing to really give advice.
- [Man 2] Have you
had a business
where you decided
that it's time to give up
this is not working?
What was that
inflection point for you?
- Yeah, I mean, I do a
lot of side businesses.
Like, I've only really
run two core businesses
Wine Library and VaynerMedia.
Those are the only ones I've
ever really gone all in on.
But, yeah, I mean
I've started side projects.
I did a thing called VaynerToys
where this whole
eBay flip challenge
I tried to do with buddies,
like Cork'd the
wine social network.
I have jumped off of businesses
that I owned a big piece of
but I wasn't the operator.
I haven't done it when
I've been the operator.
I've seen them through.
So I haven't had that exact
I'm the guy steering the ship
and I have to jump off.
I haven't had that experience.
But I also don't
build businesses
for anything other than forever.
Biggest problem with
a lot of people in here
and the reason they will lose,
the single reason
they will lose is
from the day they
start their business
they're building it to sell.
They want the money.
That's why they lose.
- [Man 2] Thank you.
- [Man 3] What do you think
the future is of advertising
and influencers between
influencers coming in.
What recommendations
would you have
for young influencers
in different markets?
- [Gary] I think
influencer marketing
is gonna have an incredible
golden era of a decade.
I think we're in
the beginning of it
and I'm very fond of it.
I think it's underpriced.
I think the top is overpriced.
So the people
that moved quickest
and have big audiences
I think are overpriced
because people think they're
more valuable then they are.
You got to look at engagement.
The amount of people
that have a million followers
on Instagram but they
don't really have a community.
Things like that.
Word of mouth always worked.
- [Man 3] Right, right.
- I'm very bullish.
My recommendation
is don't run around
saying that
you're an influencer.
Think about how to
bring value to your audience,
create influence
and then monetize it.
Again, we are living
through the greatest era
of again, you just
put it on your profile
and you think you're it.
That's like me putting
on my profile right now,
basketball player.
(audience laughter)
Cool, but I'm not getting
paid by the Knicks. Right?
The amount of accounts
that hit me up on DM like
"Yo, I'm an influencer".
I click and I'm like, "You have
800 people following you."
"Yeah, but", I'm like no, no
you're not an influencer.
By definition of
anybody's influence.
If you have that in
your profile put a word
in front of it:
aspiring influencer.
(audience laughter)
I'm very bullish on it.
I think it's
underpriced right now.
I also see,
because it's human beings,
a scenario where
in two to three years
it's gonna grossly overpriced.
You just have to
follow the market.
Right now it's underpriced.
- [Man 3] Right.
- [Daymond] We're
gonna take one more
from the in house audience.
- [Man 4] Thanks.
My question is scaleability in
regards to people.
- [Gary] Yes, tough.
- [Man 4] That's my
pain point right now.
We've gone almost nine years
now and we've hit a spot.
I can't find good people.
You invest in people and
that's one of your things.
- Are you the decision maker?
- [Man 4] Yes. A lot
of agencies as well.
They all went to Vayner.
- Okay. (chuckles)
- [Man 4] You acquire great
people just by people that
I work with.
That's my pain point.
What do you do?
'Cause none
of the sites work.
- Yeah, I agree.
How many people do you interview
for every person that you hire?
What's a rough number you think?
- [Man 4] At least 10 to 12.
- It sounds like you're just
gonna have a funnel problem.
That's not that bad.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
Here's my answer.
- [Daymond] Get a
desk here at Blueprint,
you'll find people here.
Trust me.
- I love the hustle.
I really think
that peoples flaw is,
so one of the reason's I
think we've been successful
is I'm not crippled by hiring.
I focus on firing.
I think way to
many people are fancy
and think they're
a so good at hiring.
Everybody's got this dream
that they're so good at hiring.
I think I have unbelievable EQ
skills and people intuition.
I think it actually all I've
got and I've mis-hired a ton.
I think too many people
are fancy in their hiring.
They have this bullshit
self esteem within themselves
that they're good at it.
My answer to you is to,
if you're number
is one out of twelve
and you can't get more in
I would just hire
three out of twelve
because people
will surprise you.
My model is more of
Vayner gets the most out of you
and thus if you're a B
you'll be a B+ with me.
I'm also not crippled.
You need B's and C's.
I love when my friends are like,
"How do you get your employees
to care as much as you?"
I'm like, "I don't."
The fuck should an
employee care as much as I do?
It's my business.
They need to
care about their life.
- [Daymond] Do you bring in the
B's and C's and make them A's.
- Sometimes.
- [Daymond] My
staff started as interns
at one time or another
in college, of course.
I don't look for
the perfect person.
Though I want them
to come fit in a perfect way
but they're gonna
come in with their flaws.
That's what I find.
- [Gary] I would say that
also everybody's definition
of an A is different.
I would just be more optimistic.
I mean that.
It's a funny little switch
of optimism versus cynicism
and pessimism
on the hiring front
that could really work for you.
I think that puts
pressure on you to be better.
You know? I know that
I have less of a filter in.
Which puts pressure
on us to be better
at giving them
opportunity to succeed.
Plus, once
they're in, we spend most
of the first three to
six months auditing them
and then
reverse engineering them
and putting them in the
best positions to succeed
'cause not everybody
does everything well.
I genuinely believe that I work
for everybody that works for me.
Not the other way around.
- [Daymond] We're
gonna take two questions
from live streaming.
- [Man] If people
still have questions,
use the hashtag
#blueprintgaryvee.
That's GaryVee, two e's.
(audience laughter)
- I'm so good at branding
I created my username
to be two silent fucking E's.
(audience laughter)
- [Man] Eric Davis asks,--
- Eric Davis
the Cincinnati Red's
phenomenal baseball player?
- [Man] Not that Eric.
- Got it.
(audience laughter)
- [Man] Is there long term
downside to moving too fast?
Is there balance being
aggressive and respectful?
- Again, the biggest
fear I have right now
is that we are in the
greatest era of blanket advice.
It's just like general advice.
I have to move fast.
Everybody tells me
Vayner was not going
to be successful
if I moved too fast.
They were wrong cause I'm fast.
I like action.
When I walk
through Vayner's office
if it's quiet I freak out.
I tell people, play music.
I need the action.
I need to go fast
and I'm a good enough
salesperson to
compensate for the overhead
and I can stay ahead of it.
I think you grow as
fast as you're capable.
Right? I think that,
that person Eric Davis
needs to know how
good he is to grow as fast.
Listen, everything doesn't
work and everything works.
Let's play out the scenario.
I grew too fast.
I couldn't afford my staff.
I had to cut people.
Then people got scared that
we weren't stable they quit
and my shit got fucked up.
That's scary of going too fast.
Let me tell you what
happens way more often.
90% of this room
is going too slow
and has left tons
of money on the table
but they don't know
it 'cause it's hidden.
People are scared of the hidden
and they're safe on
the black and white.
It's obvious if
you went too fast
and you broke and
you had to let people go.
It's not obvious to anybody
if you're doing a million
but you should be
doing $3 million
but you're going too slow.
People are scared
because they care
about what other people think.
- [Daymond] Next
question, are we cool?
- [Man] Alright, cool.
We have Paula Wolf.
What's the most
effective way to market
small business
who are on a budget?
- Doing stuff that
doesn't cost money.
(audience laughter)
So Wine Library, first
year $14,000 marketing budget.
I printed shit on my computer
and went to the Short Hills Mall
and put it on people's,
like, you know, the flyer's
on your fuckin' windshield?
Like ghetto shit.
(audience laughter)
I wish I had
fuckin' social media.
You like that, right?
Like it was just like,
you do what you can,
I mean I love
when everybody's like,
"Well it's easy for you."
It wasn't always.
- [Daymond] Power of broke.
- You know like,
it wasn't always.
Like, you weren't with me
when I was in my house printing
on that slow ass computer,
you know, 20% off a case of wine
and then I grabbed
the whole thing
and then I fuckin'
woke up at 6 A.M.
and went to the Short Hills Mall
and just went and
put that on the flyers,
you weren't with me.
- [Daymond] One last one?
Alright, I'm
gonna take one last one.
- Let me, can I expand on that?
- [Daymond] Yeah, of course.
(audience laughter)
(thumping)
We're fancy.
We're fancy, 'cause it's
been good for eight years.
I'm telling you right now,
look yourself in the mirror,
if you have ambitions to win,
you're fancy.
You're fancy.
People think
things are below them.
I still don't think
things are below me.
Like nothing is below me.
I'll do anything.
People got fancy,
want to play the
part of entrepreneur.
You can act all you want.
The market's coming.
Wait 'til there's no VC money.
Wait 'til you actually
have to make money.
- [Daymond] Stop comparing
everybody's sizzle reel
to your blooper reel.
Everybody's going
through the same stuff.
So you have to
exercise the power of broke,
no matter if, the people I know
exercise the power of broke
more than anybody else,
are the people that have money.
- [Gary] 100%.
- All the lines that,
you know, my partners and
I play out after we
were already established
instead of going and
a normal clothing line
would take about
120 days and about $50,000
to create the
entire product line.
I could go to Ralph Lauren
and rip the label off of here,
sew some embroidered
crap on it, the name,
pay somebody $2,500,
put it in a video,
and sit there and watch it,
the phone's gonna ring.
Phone rings, alright,
make some more shirts.
And I save time, I save
energy, and I save the cost.
And the hustle never stops
when we're talkin' about that.
You have to think OPM
is other people's money?
No it's other people's
manufactured mind power,
marketing, mentors,
and making money for
other people's mistakes.
I want everybody to
give it up for GaryVee.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Thank you Gary for having me.
And being here with us,
I appreciate it.
Let's get the
fuck up outta here.
I could use those words now.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Daymond] Thank you, man.
Good?
- Great.
- Thank you.
- I still want
to talk about fancy.
- Oh wait, let's
talk about fancy.
- Can we stay another minute?
- This is what makes him him.
- Can we stay?
I'm not fulfilled yet.
On this, I mean this.
I don't know,
Tyler how am I doing?
We doing alright?
Yana's in the crowd right?
She's somewhere here?
Yana.
We're fancy.
We have to have this
conversation in this space.
Like, we've got to.
Every entrepreneur in
here has it so much better.
It's called the
internet at scale.
So many things are easier
than what we came up with.
Right, you can DM the person
and maybe get to them.
I just, I want you guys to win
which is why I talk about this.
Like, when the money dries up,
when the economy gets tighter,
all of this goes away,
and the majority of
this market right now is
on bubble gum and dreams
and like, you've got
to know how to make money.
Like, you have
to have a business.
Your product has to bring value.
Like the tried and
true is the only thing
that's gonna
make you successful.
People running around
here trying to raise money.
Oh, I can't raise money
because I didn't go
to that kind of school.
Or I can't raise money
because I didn't come
from that kind of neighborhood.
Don't raise money.
Make money.
It doesn't take a hero to give
up a piece of their business.
Make it.
- [Daymond] So all the
balls to the wall concept.
Should you quit
your day job or not?
- I think you have to
be practical and hungry.
Like, you should
not quit your day job
if you've got crazy
compounding interest
on your student loans,
or you got to pay your mortgage.
But what you shouldn't
do is have that job,
talk shit that you're gonna
build some big business one day,
and then at 6 o'clock
at night not work.
Like you need to
go to sleep at 3 A.M.
Like you need to back
your fuckin' mouth up.
Everybody's talkin' shit.
Everybody loves to hit
me up, GaryVee hustling,
I look at their account
and they're like
playing ping pong at 4:30.
(audience laughter)
Like people don't
understand what hustle is.
I took one vacation in my 20s.
But I have crazy aspiration.
You should take 11.
But don't come telling me
you're gonna buy the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
And so like, the first thing
is figure out who you are,
and what you want.
And then deploy
real self-awareness.
But I'm telling you,
the thing that I'm fearful of
and the reason I didn't
step off stage yet is
it's been so good
for almost a decade.
This has been easy.
There's so much money out there.
Everybody's getting
money for their dumb ideas
that make no money.
And if you're not,
then you should
really even question that.
Like if you haven't
been able to raise money,
you really fuckin' suck
because the market is
ridiculously ridiculous,
like terrible.
Like people are
getting funded for everything.
So if you haven't been able
to figure out how to get money,
you're a triple loser.
(audience laughter)
So the way to answer
that and punch me in the face
and tell me that you're not
is go make money
instead of dwelling
why you haven't raised it.
I promise you
something about money.
Money's real funny.
Real funny.
Money doesn't care
what you look like.
You may think it does
but that's your fuckin' excuse.
Money wants to make money.
I'll give a Patriots fan money,
that's how much
I want to make money.
(audience laughter)
You understand?
You can say
anything you want about
you don't look the part.
White woman, black woman,
not from this country.
Money wants to make money.
So if you're not
getting it, you suck.
So then go make it
instead of dwelling that
the old white guy in VC land's
not giving me any money.
It's 'cause your shit sucks.
(audience laughter)
And so the only way
you can prove me wrong
is to go execute.
(upbeat music)